members to reference each other in the
courteous and orderly fashion finally I
want to Welcome to our Gallery the
Ukraine ambassador
[Applause]
you're right
foreign
your absence we generally do not allow
Applause in this chain
but on this occasion the house quite
right
wants to demonstrate our respect and
support for your country and its people
in the most difficult of time
[Applause]
before we start I would like to point
out the blitzwing language
interpretation proceedings available to
watch on Parliament live TV we now come
to questions prime minister I call
Graham Stewart
thank you Mr Speaker question one prime
minister Mr Speaker yesterday I was in
Warsaw and Italian reaffirming our
commitment to Nato and our solidarity
with Ukraine
simply miscalculated in his abhorrent
assault on The Sovereign Nation he has
underestimated the extraordinary
fortitude of the Ukrainian people and
the unity and resolve of the Free World
in standing up to his barbarism
the UN General Assembly will vote later
today and we call on every nation to
join us in condemning Russia and
demanding that Putin turn his tanks
around
if instead Putin doubles down then so
shall we further ratcheting up economic
pressure and supporting Ukraine with
Finance with weapons and with
humanitarian assistance today the
disasters and emergency committee is
launching its Ukraine appeal and every
pound donated by the British people will
be matched by the government starting
with 20 million pounds Mr Speaker this
morning I had meetings with the
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Reb Stuart
men women children terrorized murdered
and maimed indiscriminate Munitions
Unleashed on civilian populations with a
total disregard both for international
law and human life
can my right honorable friend assure the
house that we will accelerate the
transfer of military supplies to the
ukrainians and maintain this country's
proud record of support for refugees
fleeing War
I thank my right honorable friend and I
I hope I can say that uh I speak for the
whole house when I uh spoke to President
Vladimir zielinski this morning and I
told him uh Mr Speaker that we would
indeed do everything we can to
accelerate our transfer of the uh
shipments that he uh described of the
weapons that he describes and the UK's
house notes was uh the first European
country to send uh such defensive
weaponry and we are certainly determined
to do everything we can to help
ukrainians fleeing the theater of
conflict we now come to the leader of
the opposition the right honorable
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker I'm very glad the
Ambassador is here so he can hear me
repeat what I've said to him privately
on a number of occasions and that is
that this house and this country stad
United in our support for the Ukrainian
people in the face of Russian aggression
and we're all appalled by the shocking
footage that's emerged over the last few
days we must stand up to Putin and those
who prop up his regime
Mr Speaker Roman Abramovich is the owner
of Chelsea Football Club and various
other high value Assets in the United
Kingdom
he's a person of interest to the home
office because of his links to the
Russian State and his public association
with corrupt activity and practices
last week the Prime Minister said that
Abramovich is facing sanctions he later
corrected the record to say that he
isn't
well why on Earth isn't he
uh Mr Speaker it's not appropriate for
me to comment on individual uh cases at
this stage but and it but what I can say
and and I I I I stand Mr Speaker by what
I've uh said in the house and uh and
what we've put on the record uh but uh
being no doubt that the actions that
we've already taken that this house has
already taken are having an effect in uh
in Moscow and by exposing the ownership
of properties of of companies in the way
that we are uh by sanctioning uh 275 uh
individuals already a further 100 uh
last week uh that the impact is being
felt and what we will publish in
addition uh Mr Speaker is a full list of
all those Associated uh with the Putin
regime uh of course we've already
announced sanctions on Putin and lavrov
uh themselves and I can tell the house
that the uh they will have heard what
the president United States had to say
last night uh the vice is tightening on
the Putin regime and it will continue to
tightener
I heard what the Prime Minister says and
the way in which he puts it and I hope
that there may I mean we'll see some
action in the near future
last week Putin summoned to the Kremlin
the Cronus who prop up his regime
they dip their hands in the blood of
Putin's War among them was Igor shuvalov
Putin's former deputy prime minister
shivalov owns Two Flats not five minutes
walk from this house their worth over 11
million pounds he is on the EU sanctions
list but he's not on the UK sanctions
list when will the Prime Minister sort
this out
Mr Speaker I think the highest should be
proud of what we have done already
and and I can I can tell him uh that uh
there is more to be done and thanks to
the powers that uh this house and this
government has taken and we can sanction
any individual any company uh connected
connected with the Putin regime and this
government was uh amongst the first in
Europe to to ban aeroflot uh Mr Speaker
from our skies uh this government Led
Led the way last week in Banning uh the
use of Swift Mr Speaker and and and if
you talk to all any of our European
Partners uh he would uh understand the
the leading role the UK has already
played and the impact the impact impact
that those
oceans are already having in Moscow and
as I've as I've told him the squeeze is
growing and it will continue to grow on
the Putin regime
Mr Speaker I support the measures that
have been taken so far
uh the ownership of shivalov's flats is
registered under silver real estate
which is actually owned by shivalov on
his wife
we only know which oligarch lurks
beneath that shell company because of
the information obtained and disclosed
by Alexa balvani
now Varney of course was poisoned by the
Russian State and he now sits in a Putin
jail
transparity is essential to rooting out
corruption it should be built into our
law but it's not
and I'm ashamed
that we only know about shivalov's
Westminster Flats because a dissident
risked his lives
is the prime minister
uh Mr Speaker I I've repeat uh that the
the UK uh of course uh is doing
everything that we can to expose
ill-gotten Uh Russian Loot and this has
been something that we've been working
on for a a long time that we've actually
were the first to impose sanctions on
those who who poisoned who are guilty
for the poisoning of Alexi navalny that
he mentions but what we are bringing
forward now is is the exposure of the
ownership of properties in London you
know and across the whole of the UK in a
way that has not been possible before
and that I believe will continue to
tighten the Noose around Putin's regime
but being no doubt it was the UK uh Mr
Speaker that led the way on putting
sanctions on the Russian Central Bank on
putting sanctions on Russian Banks all
together and I'm afraid that we're still
out in advance of several of our friends
and partners we want them to go further
I believe that they will and we will
continue to put pressure on Mr Speaker
interactable pressure on the Putin
regime
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
refers to the long overdue economic
crime bill which to be clear we support
and will vote through on Monday with
speed the key plank to that bill is a
register of who truly owns property in
the United Kingdom
but it doesn't come into Force for
existing owners like shivalov until 18
months after the bill passes
a best that's Autumn 2023
far too long for the Ukrainian people
why are we giving Putin's cloners 18
months to quietly launder their money
out of the UK property market and into
another Safe Haven
Mr Speaker the impact of what the UK is
doing and which on the impact of the and
I think the whole house should be proud
of what we have done because we have
yeah
on aeroflot WE led the way on freezing
the assets of Banks and and if you if
you ask about the speed of results Mr
Speaker I can tell him that on Thursday
the Russian stock market fell by 250
billion dollars worth of assets that
were wiped off uh the ruble felt the
ruble fell by about 40 we're now in the
third day Mr Speaker in which the
Russian stock market has not been able
to open that is thanks to the package of
global sanctions a world of Western
sanctions that the UK has led in
enforcing on the Putin regime he should
acknowledge that
I have acknowledged it and I do again
what I'm offering is support to speed
this up on Monday the Prime Minister
knows he has the house with him when the
economic crime bill goes through we
could do this on Monday at speed but I
think the whole house would welcome that
so it's an invitation to work together
prime minister the business department
published a white paper this week it
rightly sets out that the UK's company's
register is being exploited to further
the interests of the UK's enemies to
help them move stolen money into the
west but the same department on the very
same day published an economic crime
bill which did nothing to address this
leaving companies house untouched and
still exploited
so will the Prime Minister work with us
to amend the bill
on Monday to include the most basic
reforms like identity checks for
directors
[Music]
as I've said Mr Speaker we are bringing
forward
an accelerated Pace measures to whip
aside the veil of anonymity of those who
own Assets in this country and those who
own property in this country in
furthermore Mr Speaker we are going to
be publishing a list of all those and Mr
Speaker who are uh who are have assets
that are that are related to the Putin
regime I'm delighted by the support that
the right honorable gentleman is
offering uh if we can work together to
make sure that we strengthen and
accelerate the package then all the
better good Starbucks
Mr Speaker we will work in that spirit
and bring forward amendments on Monday
to try and achieve all the ends that
I've identified in these questions and I
think this can be voted through on
Monday at speed with the full support of
the house and I'm very pleased that we
can show that Unity with the Ambassador
here watching us
we have seen glimmers of Hope in the
resolve of Ukraine in the unity of our
allies and in The Bravery of Russian
protesters
they remind us that the Russian people
are not our enemy they are the victims
of Thieves who've stolen their wealth
and stolen their chance of democracy
for too long Britain has been a safe
haven for stolen money
Putin thinks that we're too corrupted to
do the right thing and put an end to it
does the Prime Minister agree that this
house and this country stands United in
our support for Ukraine and now is the
time to sanction every oligarch and
crack open every shell company so we can
prove Putin wrong
hi uh yes Mr Speaker and that's why this
government has brought forward the
unprecedented and measures that uh that
we have and if I if I if I and I know
that and I know that uh the whole house
will agree with me that nothing nothing
we do in rooting out corruption and
corrupt money in in London or any other
Capital should for one minute I want to
agree with him very strongly should one
minute distract from where the true
blame for this crisis lies which is holy
and exclusively and entirely with
Vladimir Putin and and his and his
regime and I can and I'm glad that the
uh the adventures opposite are resolved
as we are that Putin must fail in his
Venture uh and that then we must ensure
and Mr Speaker that we protect a
sovereign free and independent you pray
and that is what we're going to do and
with the unity of this house Mr Speaker
with the continued heroism with the
continued heroism and resolve of the
Ukrainian people which is so amazing and
that we've seen over the last few days
and with the unity of the West that we
are seeing which I think has also taken
aback President Putin I've no doubt at
all Mr Speaker that he will fail and
that we will succeed in protecting
Ukraine Hill Paris
thank you very much thank you very much
for Mr Speaker
um can I first of all say the How brave
that the Ukrainian people are and they
have our full support across our whole
house
also commend the Prime Minister and the
government for the excellent actions we
have taken so far
Ukraine is very much the breadbasket of
the world and it grows much wheat and so
therefore prime minister I think we need
to have make sure there is food security
and also security of Global Food Supply
so would the Prime Minister agree with
me that we know me also to look to the
our production in this country to make
sure that we can maintain good standard
of food production and enhance our
food's attraction in order to keep good
food and affordable food for the future
yes my honorable friend knows here it
knows where off he speaks uh Mr Speaker
he's a great advocate of of UK food and
farming and that's why we're increasing
the farming investment fund uh to 48
million pounds we have a massive
opportunity particularly for UK fruit
and vegetables we don't come to the
leader of the s p in blackfold
thank you Mr Speaker can I join you in
welcoming the Ukrainian ambassador to
our proceedings Mr Speaker
but every passing hour the world is
witnessing the horrors of Putin's war in
Ukraine in Kirsten a family of five a
mother
her parents her six-year-old daughter
and her baby son were murdered in Cold
Blood by Russian troops in the same city
a 12 year old boy watched his mother die
as he desperately attempted to save her
from the rubble of her own home these
are war crimes happening in Europe right
now Vladimir Putin Izzy war criminal and
one day soon
Putin must face Justice in The Hague
Mr Speaker to prosecute Putin and his
regime the full range of War crime
charges need to be used including the
crime of aggression by our state but the
UK has always refused to sign up to the
prosecution of this crime and
international law surely with Putin's
crime of aggression in plain and
horrific sight in Ukraine now is the
time to drop that opposition well the
Prime Minister meet with me to discuss
this and will amend the UK war crimes
act and will he support the ICC
prosecution for Putin for his crimes of
aggression against the people
well Mrs big I'm in principle of course
happy to meet you around any stage but I
can tell him that what we have seen
already from Vladimir Putin's regime in
the use of the Munitions that they have
already been uh they've been dropping on
as on innocent civilians Mr Speaker in
my view you've already fully qualifies
as as a war crime and I know that the uh
that the ICC process computer is already
investigating and I'm sure the whole
house will support that yeah Blackford
the Prime Minister for that answer and
let's work together across this house to
make sure that Putin is prosecuted that
he is held to account Mr Speaker just as
we seek to punish and prosecute Putin
for his crimes we need to help the
Ukrainian people right now hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians are fleeing the
horrors of this war and they desperately
need refuge and Sanctuary the U.N
estimates that well over half a million
Ukrainian refugees need dungeon help
most of them women and children this is
a moment for Europe
Stand United in the face of Putin's War
the European Union have acted and waived
all visa requirements for Ukrainian
refugees the UK government stands alone
in our continent and so far refusing to
do the same Nicola sturgeon Scotland's
first Minister has made clear our
country stands ready to open our borders
in our hearts to the people of the
Ukraine but the UK government must bring
down the barriers will the Prime
Minister join with our European partners
and waive all visa requirements for the
people of Ukraine who are fleeing War
Mr Speaker the the EU already because of
its Schengen border-free Zone has its
own arrangements with Ukraine they've
differed uh for a long time from those
of the of the UK but what we do have is
a uh a plan Mr Speaker uh to be as
generous as we possibly can to the
people of Ukraine and the numbers that
will come just under our family reunion
scheme could be in the hundreds of
thousands to say nothing of the special
new path that we're opening up for those
uh coming the humanitarian path uh Mr
Speaker that is also uncapped and I
think that's the right thing to do what
we won't do Mr Speaker is uh is simply
Abandon All Checks and we don't think
that that is sensible uh particularly in
view of the security codes the the
concerns that the reasonable security
concerns about people coming from that
theater of war James daily thank you
very much Mr Speaker on the 28th of July
last year every labor counselor in Berry
voted in favor of Andy Burnham's plan to
impose a 493 square mile clean air
charging Zone upon my constituents and
the residents of Greater Manchester the
mayor's plan attacks on jobs and
opportunity is based upon flawed data
and should be scrapped does my right
honorable friend agree
[Music]
[Applause]
it's Mr Speaker this is somebody who
once had to deal with a badly thought
out
uh uh it's a low emission Zone uh before
uh it is ABS it is totally wrong to
impose measures thoughtlessly the damage
business and don't do very much to
protect cleaner and I think I think the
mayor of the mayor mentioned has done
the wrong thing and I'm glad that we're
delaying I congratulate my honorable
friend and other local conservative MPS
in the Manchester area who have shown
problem senseless
[Applause]
my wales-based constituent works for the
British International School in the
Ukraine the school employs 60 British
citizens most of whom thankfully escaped
via a bus over the weekend
now I heard the prime minister's
response earlier on to my colleague from
the s p the head of the SMP but given
the lack of a humanitarian Corridor
exactly 173 UK Ukrainian colleagues from
that school are stuck in Kev and denipro
and ineligible for the home office's
humanitarian sponsorship pathway due to
the school being domiciled in the
Ukraine Wales aspires to be a nation of
sanctuary our neighbors in Ireland have
waived all visa requirements for three
years why won't he allow us to provide
the same humanitarian welcome yeah yeah
I I thank her very much and I and I I
understand I'm obviously but I know the
whole house will want to help the 173 uh
that she she mentions in in Ukraine I
think the arrangements that we have are
right and uh they will be very generous
and they already are very generous
indeed uh and I think the house should
be proud by the way of what the UK has
already done uh to take people to take
vulnerable people I think we've taken
more vulnerable people since 2015
fleeing uh theaters of conflict than any
other country in Europe
thank you very much Mr Speaker the the
nurses and doctors working at Warrington
Hospital in my constituency provide
selfless care for families living in
some of the most deprived areas of
England where life expectancy is 12
years lower than that of the national
average at the same time population has
expanded with thousands of new homes
being built in Warrington putting
pressure on Services particularly at the
General Hospital does the Prime Minister
agree with me that tackling Health
inequalities is key to leveling up and
will he support my campaign for a new
hospital in Warrington
[Applause]
uh Mr Speaker I I I'm and I know that
this government is building a record
number of of hospitals uh the total of
48 that we're building across the
country I am forbidden I'm unfortunately
from uh preempting the application
process that I know is uh his wonderful
hospital is going through but I'm
wishing him every possible success
yeah thank you Mr Speaker prime minister
the situation in Ukraine continues to
uphold most of the world and shames the
rest and importantly highlights the need
to break our economic dependency both on
Russia and on China does a prime
minister agree that our national
security must be protected and our food
energy cyber and National infrastructure
must be secure both now and in the
future from hostile governments
specifically will he commit to a real
hydrogen strategy that both industry and
trade unions like the GMB are calling
for by doubling the hydrogen production
Target for 2013.
uh yes I thank her very much and I think
a very far-sighted question and that's
exactly what we should be uh be doing
and we are moving to much more uh energy
resilience and and self-reliance I think
it was a shame uh that the party
opposite canceled uh so much of our
nuclear power whilst they were whilst
they're in or failed to uh fail to
develop it Mr Speaker but I think uh the
agenda that she is the agenda that she
is setting is absolutely right including
hydrogen
thank you Mr Speaker last September my
constituent Dylan Rich who was a
talented 17 year old footballer
tragically collapsed and died during a
youth FA Cup game
his family and his Club the West
bridgeford Colts raised money in his
honor to buy more defibrillators on site
but were faced with a vat bill of
hundreds of pounds on each life-saving
device
will my right honorable friend commit to
reviewing the vat on Commercial
defibrillators to bring them in line
with the zero rate applied to other
medical instruments and will he meet
with me Dylan's family and his Club to
discuss this much needed
I thank her very much and I think the
whole house will want to Echo my
condolences to Dylan's friends and
family and she raises a very important
and emotive issue defibrillators at the
moment are are bought through voluntary
contributions and donated to Charities
that may be eligible for that relief uh
Mr Speaker but I'm very happy to meet
with her to discuss the matter further
will the Prime Minister instruct the
conservative party to give to Ukrainian
humanitarian causes the two million
pounds they've accepted from lubov to
newkin this includes 80 000 pounds
referred to in data released today by
the Electoral Commission Now I know he
doesn't want to tell everyone with
Russian links with the same brush and
neither do I but leaked documents
they might want to listen to the
question Mr Speaker linked documents
show that Vladimir tanukin received
eight million dollars from a Russian
Member of Parliament an ally of Putin
who was later sanctioned by the United
States Mr Speaker this is an opportunity
for the conservative party and for the
prime minister to end the suspicion of
conflicts of interest with Putin whilst
showing solidarity with the Ukrainian
people
thank you
it is absolutely vital Mr Speaker if we
are to have a successful outcome in what
we are trying to do collectively United
with Ukraine that we demonstrate that
this is not about the Russian people Mr
Speaker this is about the Putin regime
to Liam Fox
thank you Mr Speaker that's my
right-honorable friend agree that
choices always have consequences
Putin has chosen he has chosen to
inflict death and destruction on the
people of Ukraine and must be made to
pay but others including those in the
Russian military and Russian oligarchs
could still choose to be on the right
side of History will my right honorable
friend and other world leaders
tell them to make the right choice and
to make it soon because in this conflict
time is life
I think my my right honorable friend has
made a very powerful and important point
and I do hope that the uh those who have
any links with the uh the Putin regime
whatever anybody any any so-called
oligarchs all those that he uh all those
who are in any way associated with their
regime take this opportunity as some
have as some Brave individuals already
have to dissociate themselves from this
barbaric invasion
thank you Mr Speaker two weeks ago in a
letter to the Prime Minister I outlined
that over half a million people in the
UK are immunocompromised and to them the
idea of living with kovid is frightening
and many Charities such as the MS
Society are not reassured by the
government's lifting of restrictions
around free testing and isolation so
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that in order to protect this group free
covid-19 testing must continue and
include their families and friends as
well as any unpaid carers so that they
can really be allowed to live with covid
Minister I thank him as I said to her I
think last week or it is absolutely
essential that those who are
immunocompromised the the clinically
extremely vulnerable continue to have
access to to free testing and the uh all
the therapies and antivirals that they
need close question Bob Seely well
excuse Mr Speaker
sorry forgive me Mr Speaker
I thank my honorable friend for his
question we're Kathy reviewing uh
responses to our recent consultation on
a range of legislative proposals to
counter State threats including foreign
agents registration uh we will update
parliament in due course absolutely
thank you Mr Speaker and I'd like to
thank the Ukrainian Ambassador dentures
okay the benefits of the rest of the
house I just said Thank you to him and
thank you sir
key oligarchs enforced the kremlin's
hybrid conflict conflict in Britain one
of its aims is to ensure safe passage
for money flows offshore whilst law
firms intimidate into silence those who
would investigate be it the media or
even the National Crime agency does the
Prime Minister understand that this is
how State corruption happens and this is
systemic planned subversion does he
realize the seriousness of what's been
happening to the law firms and the
finance companies in recent years
I I think he's raising a very a very
important point and the uh law firms in
this country regulated by the solicitors
regulation Authority they were reminded
on the 23rd of February of the need to
comply with sanctions uh regulations and
legislation and there are regular checks
to ensure that they are doing so they
have responsibilities under that regime
to safeguard the UK and to protect the
the reputation of the United Kingdom
Legal Services industry and clearly they
will face sanctions if they face to do
if they fail to do so
Chris Brown thank you thank you Mr
Speaker Putin is the only enemy but I do
feel ashamed
the United Kingdom signed the Budapest
Accord in 1994 guaranteeing the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
23
men who once sat on these benches gave
their lives for Plucky little Belgium
they have shields down that end
22
did the same for Poland they have
shields down this end
and we're not guaranteeing the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
we're not even I don't want war nobody
wants War
but we're not even
sanctioning Sergey shoigu the Russian
defense minister yet
nor Igor osipov the commander of the
Black Sea Fleet auras manov section
peskov Abramovich Roald Dugan or the
members of the Russian Duma who voted
for this war why don't we use
parliamentary privilege to get this out
there so the lawyers can't attack the
sanctions that we must surely bring
rapidly today
uh Mr Speaker I I hear him and I know I
know that the whole house I will
understand his his feelings and his
frustration that uh that no country in
the west is going directly to the
support of the ukrainians with uh with
direct military assistance and uh and
that is a a reality that we simply have
to accept because the consequences the
consequences of a direct confrontation
between uh the UK and uh and Russia
would be I think and indeed other
Western countries in Russia would not be
easy to control and if I can repeat the
point I made earlier I think they would
play directly into Putin's narrative
that this is about he says it's about
him versus the West he says it's about
him uh versus Nato we say it's about him
versus the Ukrainian people Mr Speaker
and that's uh that is I'm afraid the
difference and as for his as for his as
for his as for what he says about uh
about shame actually I'm proud of what
the UK has been able to do so far I'm
I'm proud uh that I'm proud that we've
we've given a lead not just on sanctions
Mr Speaker where we insisted on the
toughest measures including uh for Swift
which had a dramatic effect but also we
were in the lead Mr Speaker in of All
European countries in offering military
assistance to Ukraine and we will
continue to do so I know that he would
like to go further I honestly if I
understand him correctly he would like
to go further but I can tell the house
that we are going to continue to go
further not just with military
assistance but also by tightening the
Vice on the Putin regime
yeah
Mr Speaker in addition to the tragedy in
Ukraine I know the Prime Minister also
wants to slash red take to make Britain
more internationally competitive David
Cameron succeeded but after he left we
abandoned his proven one into our regime
and added billions in red take costs
instead last month's benefits of brexit
brexit document repeats the mistake
vetoing one in two out for another
toothless regime can I urge the prime
minister to step in before it's too late
otherwise The Blob will win and we will
fail to deliver a key benefit of brexit
um Mr Speaker I'm delighted to say that
we have a new secretary of state uh for
for post-brexit freedoms
and and that he is right he is driving a
campaign to reform repeal and replace
outdated uh legislation and regulation
across the board and I don't know about
the blob uh Mr Speaker I can think of no
more uh fearsome antagonist uh for the
blob than my right honorable friend
hello
thank you Miss
[Music]
[Applause]
satellite images show a 40 mile long
Convoy of military hardware heading
towards surrounding the cities of
Ukraine
we know from grozny what the intention
of Vladimir Putin is going to be Mr
Speaker hundreds of thousands of people
are going to be murdered in these cities
think of in this house everybody think
your families think of your neighbors
think of relatives you may have a ball
they are going to be murdered now the
Prime Minister has led the world in the
reaction to what's going on and I'm
proud of what he's done so can I ask my
right and my friend I know he's probably
not been to bed for a week but can I ask
him to use every second he's got
remaining until this tragedy is surely
going to unfold to try and prevent it
from happening
uh Mr Speaker this was of course one of
the subjects that I discussed uh this
morning with uh with Vladimir zielinski
and uh and I think to many people
looking at it too if I just feel quickly
Mr Speaker they will wonder why it is
impossible uh to interrupt the progress
of those tanks with uh with airstrikes
or uh from a drone for instance which we
know that the ukrainians have
technically unfortunately it turns out
Military it is not as easy as you might
think uh Mr Speaker and the tragic
reality is that Vladimir Putin is going
to continue to grind his War Machine uh
forwards if we if he possibly can that
is why it is vital that we continue the
military support that we are offering
and that is why it is also vital that
together with the United States with all
our friends and partners in the west we
intensify and accelerate the program of
economic sanctions that is already
hurting double Abrahams thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker London is known as
the world's capital for corrupt Russian
money a hundred billion pounds a year is
a wash in our country and this the scale
of this corruption couldn't happen
without without what the intelligence
and security committee uh describe as
the enablers the lawyers the accountants
the pr Specialists and so include
including those who challenge our brave
independent journalists for for
identifying them
the Prime Minister didn't respond fully
I think to The Honorable members from
from the Isle of Wight in terms of how
he will tackle the activity of these
enablers who are for too long have been
the corrupting the rule of law in our
country yeah yeah I I think well I I
with great respect Mr Speaker let me
repeat uh again in fact reinforce what I
said to Myra normal fund around a friend
from the Isle of wait uh the the legal
profession everybody involved in
assisting uh those who wish to hide
money in London assisting a corrupt
oligarchs have been set on notice uh
that their actions are under scrutiny
and where they break the law if they
break the law if they undermine the
interests of this country of Advance the
interests of Putin's War Machine they
will pay a price slowly Kelly thought
thank you Mr Speaker in the last few
days I've been overwhelmed and heartened
by the incredible response of my
constituents to the crisis them in
Ukraine with countless offers of
accommodation and financial support for
refugees
but the community sponsorship route is a
very slow process and it will struggle
to meet the challenge that we face so
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that we need a faster and more effective
route and a better way of offering
Sanctuary to the refugees and the people
of Ukraine then the the government's
current proposals
uh I thank her very much I know that
those sympathies of the whole answer are
with her and what she's trying to do uh
and we are we are I've talked to our
polish friends uh yesterday about what
we can do in partnership with them uh to
bring people directly to the to the UK
who are fleeing uh to uh to Poland uh
and I've set out for the houses I know
my right on from the Home Secretary has
already uh the the big big package of
measures that we're putting in to help
people uh fleeing uh fleeing Ukraine I
just want to repeat and look at the
numbers we took from Afghanistan look at
the numbers of bnos of uh from Hong Kong
uh huge numbers of people uh that have
come to the UK and I think that we've
settled uh 25 000 vulnerable people uh
since 2015 uh which is more than any
other European country so we should be
proud of our record he's under Stafford
my grandfather poor Chris Clover was
Ukrainian was reported by the Soviets
the gulags of Siberia I am proud of my
Ukrainian Heritage never more so than
over the past week with Plucky Nation
the nation of my family has stood up the
Jack Butte of Putin's Army I know the
world is watching the PM and our country
will the Prime Minister give me his
assurances that he will continue to look
at every single possible option to show
that Fusion is the toughest range of
punitive sanctions both through
financial measures but also focusing on
his inner circle
yes Mr Speaker and that's why we've
begun with him and we're also with uh
with Sergey lavrov but there is no
limits to uh what we can do on his uh on
his regime and we will continue to do
that can I just Echo what he said about
uh our bond our our debt to the
Ukrainian people never never forget when
we stood side by side uh with Russia uh
in the 1940s against fascism uh Mr
Speaker there was there was a Ukrainian
Army a Ukrainian contribution to that
Army was 10 million people and they were
absolutely invaluable in Freedom as well
Angela Crawley
prime minister Scotland stuff ready to
any flea
follow the example of the European Union
of a red tape visa-free approach will
this prime minister commit to an
unconditional Rapid Safe and legal
approach to settlement for ukrainians
fleeing this Invasion why is he failing
to do so
Mr Speaker we as I've explained to the
house already several times the the EU
has a border-free Schengen Zone it's not
appropriate for them to have checks of
any kind we've got a different system it
is sensible given the situation that we
have and given the uh the uh the large
numbers of people leaving that uh war
zone it's sensible to have uh checks and
and to make sure Mr Speaker that we we
know who is coming in but what we will
not do is impede ukrainians coming uh in
fear of their lives this country as I've
said several times today has a proud
proud record of taking people in look at
what we've already done in that look at
the look at the record just under my uh
Premiership look at what we've done to
help people from our Afghanistan
look look at what we've done to help the
Hong Kong Chinese she should be proud of
what the UK is doing
it's just questions
point of order just let the championship
settle down